One of the tests to measure toxicity. Well, it depends on what toxicity you're looking for. So there are different inner
Oisins that we're exposed to that is
measured in a test. We typically use mosaic
For that. There's a toxic detect test that we run on
on
patients that test, I don't know, 30, 25 different
Poisons that are in our environment. There's a glyphosate test in itself that stands by itself to measure glyphosates.
There's Michael toxin test that is very valuable because might we talked about that in multiple questions today
Michael toxins are carcinogens. So measuring mycotoxins if you have current exposure to mycotoxins that have never been dealt with and you have high levels of mycotoxin that could certainly be
something that you want to address.
Heavy metal testing is another possible test that you may want to look at.
So there's different toxicity tests that you could do by
if you call the office marine can point you to
one of the tests. I might have to get it up on this door as a stand alone. I'd like to look and see what we have.
But those are the kind of tests that you do. Those are urine tests
you could do
So those are those are the kind of toxicity tests that I'm talking about
most probably the most relative to you would be
toxic detect test and a mycotoxin test. Those are going to be the most relevant to somebody that has cancer
dealing with those type of toxins. The glyphosate tests we did on everybody for a while that I actually pulled it off
simply because everybody was positive and now we're doing it again just to show that
and some people have a struggle with that because like how could I be positive of glyphosate?
So glyphosate is rolled up which is an herbicide that is going to be folded not organic foods
but we've had people I mean I've never had people normal on glyphosate and some people struggle
with that like how could this possibly be? I've been eating nothing but organic food for the last
X years but the truth is there's so much cross contamination. The other different toxins can be
based upon a person's exposure whether you work with with chemicals you're going to obviously have
a much more higher toxic load if a person's like I never work with chemicals but you're still exposed
to toxins everywhere from flame retardants in your carpeting to your clothing to what's coming
off? Theumes that are coming off your walls to your new comforter you're bought. These things
dissipate into our airspace we breathe them in so we were exposed to so many poisons in our environment
that it made our life you know considerably easy in a first world country but then then caused
that are basically poisons so testing for these aren't necessarily something not all these things
you can like magically just oh I'm not going to let myself be exposed to those things but it does
give us clues that we just don't detoxify something's very well and we need to support that those pathways
so